قالت اداره الطيران الفدراليه ان حركه
الطيران الطبيعيه صنفت بشكل تدريجي في
جميع انحاء الولايات المتحده بعد رفع
الحظر عن الاقلاع والغيا اكثر من الف رحله
طيران داخليه وخارجيه في الولايات المتحده
اما بلغ عدد الرحلات المتاخره اكثر من سته
الاف وفقا لمواقع رصد حركه الملاحه الجويه
استعاده النظام اشعارات الطيران الوطني
بالكامل وقال الوزير في تغريدا حضر
الطيران قد رفع وانه وجه الجهات المعنيه
بتحديد اسباب العطل
وكانت وكاله الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه
قد اعلنت عن عطل الفنيه في نظام الاشارات
الجويه اثرا او اثر على عمليه الطيران
وطلبت من شركات الطيران ايقاف كل الرحلات
الداخليه حتى الساعه 9:00 صباحا بتوقيت
الساحل الشرقي
وقال رئيس الامريكي
مع وزير النقل في اتصال هاتفي ازمه
الطيران في البلاد بعد تعرض وكاله الطيران
الفيرلاليه لعطله الفنيه
تحدثت للتوي مع وزير النقل ولا يعرفون بعد
سبب العطل لكنني كنت معهم عبر الهاتف
وطالبتهم بابلاغي فور الكشف عن السبب ما
يزال بامكان الطائرات الهبوط بسلام لكن لا
يمكنها الاقلاع حتى الان لا يعرفون بعد
السبب لكنهم يتوقعون معرفته في غضون
ساعتين
التواصل الاجتماعي
في مدارس الطيران بعد تاجيل الرحلات
الجويه ومنع يطلع اي رحله في الولايات
المتحده نتيجه لعطل الاصابه بمتاوي وكاله
الطيران
تعطل الحركه الجويه بدا حوالي الساعه
الثانيه عشر والنصف بتوقيت جرينتش باعلاني
وكاله الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه انها
تسعى للسيطره على عطل فنيا في نظام
الاشعارات الجويه الثراء على عمليات
الطيران كما قالت وكاله الطيران من
الطلعات في كل انحاء الولايات المتحده
تاثرت بالاعطى في النظام في حوالي الساعه
الواحده بتوقيت جرينتش اصدر البيت الابيض
بيانا قال فيه الرئيس
العطل وانه لا دليل على وجوده هجوم
الكتروني في هذه المرحله كما ظهرت بيانات
ملاحيه لمواقع رصد حركه الطيران ان
اجماليه عدد الرحلات المتاخره داخل امريكا
وخارجها تجاوز اربعه الاف رحله وفي الساعه
الواحده والنصف اعلى نتيجه طيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه عن السنافر الرحلات
في مطار نيويورك وفي نيوجيرسي ومطار
اتلانتا في جورجيا وان طائره الموجوده في
الجو بامكانها الهبوط بسلام انه اما احراز
تقدم في استعاده النظام الاشعارات بعد
انقطاع الخدمه سياسات الثانيه بتوقيت
جرينتش اعلنت وكاله طيران الفيدراليه عوده
تدريجيه لحركه الطيران الطبيعيه في عموم
الولايات المتحده
تنضم الينا من امام مبنى اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه في واشنطن مراسله الجزيره
بيسان ابو كويك اذن بيسان السوني فتحت
حركه الطيران طبيعيه ولكن بشكل تدريجي كيف
اذا تبدو تطورات ما جرى
[موسيقى]
بالفعل مياده كما اعلنت اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه ووزير النقل بيت بوتاجاز ان
هذه العمليه استئنافت ولكن بشكلنا تدريجي
وزير النقل بوتاجاز قال قبل قليل في
تصريحات اعلاميه بانه حتى اللحظه يتم
النظر طبعا في اسباب هذا الخلل كي لا
يتكرر مره اخرى نظام نور نظام الاشعارات
كما يقول كان يرسل رسائل خاطئه قال انه لا
يوجد مؤشرات او دليل حتى هذه اللحظه على
وقوع اي هجوم سبراني ولكن هذا امر غير
مستبعد وان عمليه التحقيقات التي امر بها
وامر بها ايضا رئيس بعيدا هي لمعرفه
الاسباب كي لا يتكرر امر كهذا سمعنا ايضا
من اصوات في الكونجرس الامريكي تطالب ايضا
بانها تريد ان تنظر فيما حدث لان النظام
النظام
ونظام الطيران داخل الولايات المتحده يجب
ان يكون مارينا وتريد ايضا الاطلاع على
نتائج التقرير الذي سيعد من قبل وزاره
النقل وبالتالي اداره الطيران الفيدراليه
لمعرفه الاسباب كان هناك ايضا بعض اعضاء
الكونجرس ومنهم كبير الديمقراطيين في لجنه
النقل في مجلس النواب الامريكي اشار الى
انه يجب النظر الى وضع البنيه التحتيه
التكنولوجيه ل- انظمه اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه همم مع ان تاكدات طبعا جميعا
المسؤولين حتى اللحظه انا لا توجد مؤشرات
او دليل على وقوع هجمات سبرانيه ولكن عطل
او خلل مثل هذا مياده يثير التساؤلات
بالنسبه للمسؤولين الامريكيين وايضا في
الكونجرس حول مكانه هذا النظام وان اي عطر
كهذا قد ربما يشكل مواطن ضعف او هشاشه فيه
ان كان سيكون هناك هجوم سبراني مثلا سيتم
البحث عن طرق ربما تحديث هذه اجهزه اين
كان الخلل
ومراجعه الاسباب لعدم تكرار ما حدث اليوم
وما شل حركه الطيران داخل الولايات
المتحده بقي معنا بيسان انضم الينا من
مطار لاغوارديا في نيويورك مراسله جزيره
مراد هاشم ونرصد معك اذا كيف تبدو حركه
المسافرين وحركه الطيران عموما في هذا
المطار
ولا يزال رغم ان ال- ال- اقلاع الطائرات
قدمه تم رفعه من قبل هيئه الطيران
الفجرالي قبل اكثر من ساعتين ونصف من الان
لكنها تاثيراته لا تزال مستمره في همم
تعبيرات من قبيل استمرار همم تاجيل
الرحلات وكذلك الغائها من بين سته الاف
ومئه رحله على المستوى القومي تم تاجيلها
هناك همم 300 424 رحله هنا في مطار
لاغوارديه ومن بين همم نحو ال رحله تم
الغاءها على المستوى القومي هناك همم
120 رحله تم الغائها هنا في مطار
لاغوارديه وهو المطار الرئيسي للرحلات
المحليه هنا في مدينه نيويورك هو احد همم
ثلاثه مطارات رئيسيه لكنه المطار الرئيسي
الذي يستخدم في الرحلات المحليه ولذلك
تاثر اكثر همم على سبيل المثال الارقام في
مطار جي اف ال كندي الدولي تشير الى ان 17
رحله فقط تم الغائها حتى الان عدد بسيط من
قناه بما تم هنا في هذا المطار اضافه الى
تاجيل همم
351 رحله في مطار همم
المطار نيويورك وهو في ولايه جرس المجاوره
ولكن انه يعد احدى المطارات الرئيسيه هنا
التي تستخدم في المدينه يستانف رحلاتهم في
وقت مبكر حتى مع استمرار همم القرار همم
منع الطائرات من الاقلاع على لازلنا نرى
الجدول الرحلات هنا في هذه الصاله وهي
احدى صالات المطار وتحديدا تستخدم
في الكثير من الاعلانات عن الغاء الرحلات
وكذلك تاجيل لرحلات لفترات تزيد عن الساعه
الكامله اذا هذا الاضطراب مستمر ومن
الواضح ان الشركات تحاول ان همم
تلتزم
بالجداولها ال ال السابقه المحدده
للمسافرين ولكنها بسبب الاضطراب الذي وقع
صباحا واستمر لاكثر من ساعتين ادى هذا
بالطبيعه الحال الى اتبعات حتى الان تحاول
الشركات ان تتجاوز قدر مات همم ما تستطيع
مياده
مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا موصول لك من امامنا اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه في واشنطن مراسله الجزيره بس